[Música]
y
varios hospitales de aquí de la
comunidad de madrid superan el 90% de
ocupación entre pacientes aecovi y no
cobit una situación que ha vuelto a
poner sobre la mesa una potencial y
próxima reapertura del hospital de ifema
un hospital de campaña que se abrió en
este recinto ferial madrileño y que
estuvo operativo entre finales de marzo
y principios del mes de mayo periodo en
el cual pasaron por ese hospital de
acompaña más de 4.000 pacientes es kobe
pero por otro lado el gobierno regional
de aquí de la comunidad de madrid está
construyendo un hospital de pandemias en
este caso evidentemente ha dedicado de
entrada a la pandemia de coronavirus que
según los planes del ejecutivo madrileño
tendría que estar operativo a principios
de este mes de noviembre y este hospital
dotará de mil camas más el sistema de
salud público de aquí de la comunidad de
madrid' y al mismo tiempo supone una
inversión de 50 millones de euros y es
esta cifra precisamente en la que crea
un cierto escepticismo entre el personal
sanitario ya que tal como nos comentaba
en una médica de urgencias de un gran
hospital de aquí de madrid del gregorio
marañón lo que falta realmente es más
personal sanitario
para que estas grandes inversiones en
infraestructuras vengan acompañadas de
más contratación
[Música]
desde que empezó la crisis del
coronavirus en eeuu también se
construyeron a contrarreloj varios
hospitales de campaña el objetivo era
atender la demanda de pacientes
contagiados con lakovic 19 especialmente
en estados como nueva york o florida
donde se han registrado un gran número
de enfermos nueva york' lleva varios
meses con un bajo índice de contagios y
ha cerrado a algunos de sus hospitales
de campaña e incluso el gobierno
norteamericano anunció la donación de
dos de ellos a chile con el objetivo de
que pudieran servir para la lucha contra
la pandemia en florida los hospitales de
campaña aún siguen operativos aunque
según fuentes del estado no se han
utilizado todavía no ha hecho falta
porque los hospitales convencionales han
operado con total normalidad incluso con
los picos más altos de contagios sin
embargo funcionarios de salud temen una
segunda oleada de contagios con la
llegada del invierno además coincidiría
con la temporada de la gripe por lo que
los expertos instan a la población a no
bajar la guardia
[Música]
en méxico a pesar del elevado número de
contagios y muertes por corona virus no
ha colapsado el sistema hospitalario y
eso en buena medida es gracias a la
instalación de unidades móviles para
pacientes no graves un ejemplo de ello
es el hospital inflable de pachuca
hidalgo de fabricación española y con
lonas de tecnología noruega ahí hay una
capacidad de 40 camas de hospitalización
general y 10 más de terapia intensiva
otro ejemplo es el autódromo de la
capital del país sede del gran premio de
méxico de la fórmula 1 que este año se
canceló el inmueble se transformó en un
hospital kobe con ocho módulos y 192
camas de hospitalización general y 26
más de terapia intensiva asimismo el
centro de convenciones citi banamex se
transformó también en hospital cobit
gracias a una inversión de 32 millones
de dólares de los cuales la mitad la
aportó la fundación slim hasta ahora
tiene una capacidad de 500 camas de
hospitalización
[Música]